I've got a series of functions for you
okay I want you to answer some questions
for me on this series of functions okay
my first function is y equals one okay
why cuz one right the next function is y
equals three and my next one let's just
do another is y equals 100 okay all
right hmm okay tell me is this an
increasing function no are you sure
you're really sure yeah okay fine my
increasing what about this one it's
different
it's got big number is it increasing are
you sure you sure okay fine
right well third time lucky is this an
increasing function okay well guess what
I don't buy it I think you're all wrong
I'll tell you why I need calculus watch
do you wanna do X I know how to
differentiate things right for this
function anyway okay it's zero right
how's my calculus is it good yeah yes
without this one I'll just check it you
sure okay hold on the numbers are bigger
here so be careful okay I think I think
zero that okay
hmm so therefore I conclude I look at
these and these are sophisticated
functions but I'm quite I'm quite good
at maths I do extension to right so I'm
no exams I can say for all these three
functions that do I'll DX is greater
than or equal to zero isn't it it is all
all of these satisfy this right ah haha
but you guys all said these weren't
increasing functions what Liars that
means they're increasing right of course
they're increasing you're fired
don't do extension to anymore you missed
it or did I do something wrong
what's wrong why why is my conclusion
that these are increasing functions
because this is true of all of them why
is it wrong oh oh this is a small
problem here small problem it's not it's
not greater than equal to zero that
makes it increasing functions right it
should be greater than zero
that's an increasing function all right
but that's not what you told me right so
this was your primary error at least
half of you what's open is that at least
half of you reach this conclusion you
said f dash theta okay what was F - it
was Cypress College wasn't it
right so you said well sine feet up well
that's that's great abandon because
you're in the domain right and cause
that's great 90 Cudas are 0 in the
domain so when you add them up you get
this and that's great that is equal or
equal to zero in the domain so it's
increasing hooray just like these guys
we can all be friends right no no no no
okay so this is not this is not
qualified something to be increasing
function wrong okay others of you saw
this you like no I cut maybe you got to
this point you're like oh I can't do
that I need this to be true right so you
thought mmm a backtrack I can fix this
no problem wideout solves a lot of
things I'll say this right I'll say that
this is true in the domain how is it not
to plan to not to PI - right except in
not to PI on to sine theta
well that starts off at zero BAM okay
and then cos theta at podgy is equal to
zero
neither of these statements are true
right so if you tried to fix this by
fixing these that was bad still more of
you said up here an embarrassingly for
someone who got a lot of other things
right no it's cool it's cool
the derivative is 1 plus sine theta
add one to all of that such positive yes
sweet because I could differentiate one
and get one right right I cried I cried
I seriously cried
ok so now so therefore for actually who
got this right did anyone get the mark
no I'm yeah I thought so I kind of knew
I might now so for 24 people who got it
wrong and believe me tried a lot of
different ways you'll laugh at what was
the most simple and elegant way to prove
it
watch um here's safety night in his cos
theta okay so what does um what does F
Dash look like so I did it was close to
it up
well looks like this so in my solution I
read this see you later suckers okay
that's all we get to do you just had to
differentiate crap it's a simple graph
and all of you guys like are do we have
to graph takes so long
yeah I bet it took a long time right and
it's such an elegant way look of course
it's been easier because right that was
the simplest we're doing one mark okay
an easy mark as well